starting off this hour is she'll be in
Tennessee Merry Christmas Shelby how can
we help today
Merry Christmas day thank you so much
for taking my call
sure so my husband and I are in the
middle of our debt snowball on our
active debt he also has a handful of
credit collections from about 2014 at
2015 and about a month ago we've
received in the mail three separate
letters from some bankruptcy lawyer
stating there was a court case against
him so I did a little digging to see if
it was valid I called the County Clerk
and she said that the court case was
valid but there's been no activity on it
and nothing has been served yet so my
predicament in question is should we
pause our debt snowball so to speak on
our active debt to pay this collection
or should we take action only if and
when something has actually served who
was it by and how much was it for I
don't even know the original creditor
it's been passed around so long but it's
in the hands of a law firm right now was
it was it a credit card or medical bill
what was it do you know I believe it was
some sort of personal loan from I think
they were called the Lending Club at
first and it's for about $3,000 which is
what kind of makes me nervous because
that's going to take us at least three
months to pay that full amount and kind
of pause everything else we've been
doing I'm really conflicted about what
to do because I don't know whether we
should leave if Lending Club has a three
thousand dollar unsecured loan that is
five years old they don't own it anymore
they sold it mm-hmm
they sold it for probably around six or
seven cents on the dollar so they
probably paid under two hundred dollars
for this okay mm-hmm and so if you were
to contact the law firm and offer them a
thousand dollars they'll probably settle
it you'll probably have to argue with
them
listening listen to some whining and
troughing around and all that kind of
stuff that's part of a negotiation with
any collections and by the way this law
firm is no more of a law firm than fly
the moon except that they technically
have a law office what they are is a
widget a factory that prints off
lawsuits on small collections in mass
mm-hmm
okay and they probably are not going to
do much with this if they ever did
actually sue you even when they win then
the only way they would get anything is
to execute on the judgment and that
would take months more on top of it the
chances of them spending a thousand
dollars in addition to the 800 ition to
the 200 they paid for the debt to try to
collect the three thousand dollar debt
that's five years old is about zero okay
so what they do is they throw paper
around to try to intimidate people to
get them to pay the bill and you need to
pay the bill so but your the thousand
dollars in your emergency fund baby step
one right yes okay if this comes up if
it comes to a head call them and offer
them the thousand dollars and tell them
that's all you have because that would
by the way be the truth mm-hmm and
second settlement in full I can't give
you any more than that I don't have any
more than that you'll just have to sue
us okay and then then then they'll they
will show you and then they would win
because you're the money and then you go
back you settle the Ludd the judgment
later because it's gonna take all of
this takes way too long and generally
what they do is they play the odds they
buy bad debt and they play the odds
and they and so they they go in down
there where they like if you can imagine
going in with two wheelers full of cases
of lawsuits and they file them all at
once
it's like a factory doing a shipment
mm-hmm and then they just hope a few of
them hit and all they got to do is hit
about one in ten and their money comes
back mm-hmm and so that's how it's a
game they took odds they're playing the
odds and debt buyers are real slimy and
the law firms that they work with or
real slimy by and large there's a few
exceptions but 90% of them are slimy so
just deal with it like you're dealing
with slimy people when they get
everything in writing and don't give
them any access to your checking account
do not give them any employment
information do not give them anything
except a cash offer in return for a in
writing settlement offer okay then I'll
send you a cashier's check or a I'll
wire some money or I'll do a prepaid
debit card that you turn on long enough
to put that money in there and then you
turn it back off something like that
where they do not have access to your
job they don't have access to your
current address well we need to verify
your information before we can have this
conversation well do you want the
conversation to end or do you want to
get some money because you're not
verifying spit with me because all the
information they get on you is going to
help them file a garnishment against
your wages or something and don't give
them anything so you got to play hard at
all
hardball be real cagey wise as serpents
harmless as doves and try to get this
settled when it comes up but right now
it really hasn't come up yet
okay helpful perfect yes that was
exactly what I needed to know thank you
very careful and very wise okay don't
trust anything you hear only trust what
you see okay okay thanks for the call
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five let me help you
guys with this because occasionally I
get a question about this
there are basically three or four types
of collectors out there there's a
collector that calls you on your home
mortgage if you have a traditional home
mortgage in your behind they will call
you from the mortgage company say we
want our money they can be believed they
don't have a lot of power but they have
a precise system that they have to go
through in order for the FHA insurance
to kick in the VA insurance to kick in
or the Fannie Mae PMI to kick in okay
and so for them to get the coverages in
the event of foreclosure that they need
they have to go through a very precise
procedure and they generally are not
going to bluster and create a bunch of
emotion and all that kind of stuff so
your mortgage collector is probably the
top of the heap the best collect
out there in terms of telling the truth
and they're gonna be tough on you they
you own money they're trying to get
their money but in terms of telling the
truth the bottom of the barrel is a debt
buyer that buys it for a nickel on the
dollar and they're working the odds and
they're really really really slimy right
above them are the credit card
collectors with the national companies
like Discover and Chase and Wells Fargo
and so on if you get a collections call
from a credit card collector in one of
those companies be aware you are dealing
with some of the worst human beings on
the planet their trash they're slimy and
if you don't like me calling you that
and you're one of those collectors then
go get a job you can be proud of because
you're slimy okay and navient is just
right there just above them they will
lie to you and they're incompetent when
it comes to your student loans so you
have to be careful your local collection
agency in your local town usually pretty
good folks but not always so you can't
be sure but some of those are pretty
good folks too there's a gradient than
the quality of human you're dealing with
in these collections processes and just
be aware of that if you're getting
behind on your bills because you got to
work through this mess
[Music]